et puis neuf jours après le départ des
derniers réfugiés de sangatte la
destruction du grand hangar de la croix
rouge a débuté ce matin les pelles
mécaniques sont entrés en action sous le
regard des habitants du village
christelle sabarot et bruno espaly entre
les mâchoires d'une gigantesque pince
coupante c'est le hangar de sangatte qui
s'effiloche l'étole et les poutres
métalliques ne résiste pas en quelques
minutes l'entrée du centre est arrachée
visages fermés les larmes aux yeux
quelques salariés de la croix rouge sont
venus assister à cet étrange spectacle
pour eux c'est la fin d'une histoire ce
qu'on a vécu l inverse est unique
vraiment unique
chacun ses propres histoires chacun ces
petits moments ces petits coups durs et
je crois que c'est le plus gros coup dur
qui puisse arriver à l'histoire du
vraiment au début du mois les accords
franco-britanniques avait tablé la
fermeture du centre pour le 30 décembre
mais le temps s'est accélérée les
derniers réfugiés sont partis le 14 et
la croix-rouge a vidé les lieux vendredi
eurotunnel qui vient de récupérer le
site a immédiatement entrepris sa
démolition le gouvernement français
était rapide à mettre en place des
mesures pour arrêter cette situation et
on nous a demandé d'aller vite
donc ce hangar devait être démoli quoi
qu'il arrive donc plutôt d'attendre on a
démarré maintenant vers la fin nous
avions jusqu'à 100 personnes par par
jour qui arrive et ce qui était énorme
mais je crois qu'il fallait bien marquer
auprès des
maison de passeurs mafieux que c'était
terminé qu'on ne pouvait qu il ne
pouvait plus compter sur un réservoir
comme l'était sans gamme
les travaux de démolition doivent durer
une semaine
mais en quelques heures près du quart de
la structure était déjà tombé dans un
mois ce hangar qui a vu passer soixante
huit mille réfugiés aura définitivement
disparu